(elevator dings)
(doors scraping)
- Hey, it's me, yeah, Joanna Stern!
You didn't recognize me?
You don't like my new look?
But really, that's me!
Well, this is me, this is real-life me,
and that's avatar, virtual-reality me,
but actually, I'm getting a little tired
from working from home in the same space,
so I'm gonna go back in here.
(playful music)
I think I'll also go here, and here.
Yes, the office.
Sure, when COVID-19 first hit
and we all went into lockdown,
video calling brought us together.
It was even fun.
But now, the Zoom fatigue is real.
I rarely even look at
my colleagues anymore.
So I've turned to virtual
reality, and as it turns out,
an increasing number of
Fortune 500 companies
are embracing this technology, too.
It makes sense, as companies have extended
work-from-home policies until late 2021,
or even indefinitely,
they're looking at ways to bring
individuals and teams together.
Plus, even before the pandemic,
virtual reality used within businesses
was forecasted to grow
from 829 million in 2018
to 4.26 billion in 2023.
So, a few months ago,
when it became apparent
we weren't going back to
the office anytime soon,
I started trying it out for myself.
I had a lot of questions.
Can virtual interaction
really mimic the real world?
What do you need to make it all work?
Can you really be productive in there?
Will I feel like I need
to barf all the time?
(groans) Oh boy.
To test it all out, I
worked with a startup
out of New York City called Spatial,
to recreate one of my
favorite places in the office.
Yes, the elevator.
(elevator dings)
♪ Dance, dance, dance ♪
(fingers snapping)
Okay, it's like this?
- Don't you really wanna turn
around and face backwards?
- Yes.
I spend a lot of time in
the elevator in the office.
I have a whole video
interview series in there.
It is an elevator.
- Yeah.
- [Joanna] Okay, fine, spoiler,
it's not a real elevator.
It's a three-wall set.
- Marking.
(board clacks)
- Are you Sebastian Thrun?
Are you Vijaya from Twitter?
Are you, wait, what are you?
- I'm a holographic
avatar of Anand Agarawala,
the CEO of Spatial.
- Well, nice to meet
you. Can we shake hands?
- Yeah!
(elevator music)
- Wow, wow, look at that!
We don't even need six feet.
- We can even high-five.
- Wow, so where are we?
- Spatial is basically a
holographic collaboration platform.
Imagine if Zoom had teleportation.
So you just put on a headset,
and with a realistic avatar generated
from a simple 2D photo,
you can feel like you're in
the same room with someone.
(playful music)
- Whoo!
It's actually kind of crazy
how real it feels in there.
I mean, he does not look
like him as like a real person,
but his presence feels very real.
But of course, Anand is in
his office in New York City,
and I'm in my childhood
basement in New Jersey.
My producer, also in a headset
in his home in Brooklyn.
Connecting in Spatial
was really quite easy,
and anyone can do it.
I signed up for a Spatial
account on the company's website
and uploaded a photo of myself.
Using some machine learning,
it turned that into my avatar.
Then I downloaded the Spatial app
on this new $299 Oculus Quest 2.
It works on the older one, too.
It also works on a Microsoft HoloLens
augmented reality headset,
oh, which, you know, just costs $3,500.
All right, let's do it.
You don't need any extra
hardware with those headsets.
All the head and hand tracking just works.
When I move my head, so does my avatar's.
When I move my hands, so does my avatar's.
Then you can join one of
the spaces Spatial makes.
The company made this
custom elevator for me,
but the preset Spatial meeting rooms
are being used by all sorts of companies.
Do you have a sense of
who's using Spatial,
what types of companies?
- Anywhere from 40% of the Fortune 1000
to just regular small teams
and people trying to stay connected.
So some of the customers are like Pfizer,
Mattel, the manufacturing company,
also companies in fashion,
government agencies,
intelligence agencies.
- What about the spaces themselves?
Are people customizing them to look
like their real office spaces?
- Yeah, so that's been
a huge feature request.
We've added a couple more environments
like a board room and even an abstract one
where you can overlay your own,
but we are gonna add support for that.
- [Joanna] Within the
spaces, you can talk,
but you can also use 3D tools
to brainstorm and look at presentations,
or even manipulate objects, like 3D dogs.
- You can virtually pet 'em.
- Browser? Where are you?
Browser? You're gonna get a 3D avatar.
I have a real dog that's much cuter
than all of these right now.
For real, though, the chief
technology officer at Mattel
told me employees use Spatial to meet up
and review 3D models of
toys and store displays.
(playful music)
Of course, Spatial isn't perfect,
and certainly misses a
lot of things about a true
person-to-person office
conversation or elevator ride.
For instance, facial cues
and even body language.
Like when I asked,
you've built something pretty cool here.
Has any big company tried
to come and buy Spatial?
- You know, I mean, it depends,
you know, what is buy, what is it?
- I've asked that question a
lot of times in this elevator
and I can usually read
the facial expressions.
But I'm having a hard
time reading right now.
- I'm blushing in real life
and sweating and squirming,
but you know, I just seem
like cool, calm and collected.
- [Joanna] Then, the tech can sometimes
get in the way.
(Anand laughing)
- Buy me a drink first, Joanna, come on.
- Plus, you'll really wanna buy a headset.
Spatial does have a web app,
and its coming iPhone and Android apps
let you join in augmented reality.
That is where digital
objects are overlayed
in your real world.
But VR is far more immersive.
Spatial isn't the only
virtual meeting platform.
Another option, Mozilla Hubs,
has conference-room-like spaces,
though the avatars look pretty cartoonish.
AltspaceVR, owned by Microsoft,
is used by companies like Accenture
to hold all-hands meetings.
Facebook, which owns Oculus,
has recently launched its own social
virtual reality space called Horizon,
though it's focused on
more playful interactions.
(quirky music)
One day, and I really hope one day soon,
we'll go back to a real office.
Spatial, which was originally designed
to bring colleagues together
from various different offices,
isn't worried about that, though.
Do you ever think Spatial and VR meetings
will be as ubiquitous as video calling?
- 100%, I mean, it's not a question of if,
it's more a question of when.
There's a near-future where your next
phone or computer is gonna be glasses,
and in that future, your
FaceTime becomes 3D,
and you know, when you're
FaceTiming your mom,
she can actually be on
your couch with you.
- That seems a ways off.
For now, though, connecting
with colleagues this way
really is worth a try.
(Joanna chattering)
It isn't real life,
but it brings back some
of the serendipity of the office,
and goes deeper than just another
impersonal 2D video call.
And I promise, you can totally
get real work done in there.
(Anand humming)
(Anand laughing)
Oh no, I don't have legs!
I don't have a butt or legs!